[Music]
our friend James Corden he turns living
or Oh today and we are celebrating with
three things that we love about this
late-night funny man if I could tell my
twelve-year-old self that this would be
my life like his head would explode
you're not
[Applause]
[Music]
it got me emotional the first thing we
love about James is how surprised he is
by the mega success of carpool karaoke
the caliber and people that we've got
doing the show is mind-blowing to us it
the whole thing is it's so sort of crazy
the one I've enjoyed doing the most I
think was probably Bruno number two on
our list we loved how humble this
small-town Brit is he was relatively
unknown in America when he took on The
Late Late Show
there's just no reason why somebody from
high wycombe she kept the chance to talk
to America every night it feels very
very alien and strange but I'm thrilled
to be given such an opportunity but what
we love most about James he's a family
man who takes his parents to the Grammys
and adores the mother of his three kids
you got a pretty wife I'm punching why
about my wife
I always tell him he is way too
self-deprecating he's the cutest thing
he's adorable I think you might go
saying that I think I have a little
crush adore
[Music]